well the term social I'd actually
started in the nineteen nineteen
twenties early 1930s and actually that
was a result of for the first time
younger people going out independently
without having the let's say asserting
themselves independently socially going
basically going to nightclubs and
drinking and partying and the term
social ight was just an easy way of
saying these are people who could afford
to do this without working or didn't
have to work as much as other people and
had more time on their hands the word
socialites come back into the parlance
in a vernacular in a way that actually
is it it's just kind of the same thing
it's a way of saying these people who
seem to have a lot of time on their
hands and enough money to support
themselves without working